the fbi and the department of homeland
security have been asked to investigate
a computer hack on several u.s
government agencies the spying campaign
went on for months homeland security
says it created
an unacceptable risk senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge looks at the top suspect
in the breach the hacks into the
commerce and treasury departments are
believed to be led by the russian
government
and they appear to be related to a
recently
fireeye said sunday it believed hackers
were able to gain access
to numerous public and private
organizations around the world
by slipping malware into software
developed by solarwinds
an it management company solarwinds
products are used by hundreds of
thousands of organizations worldwide
including the military the cdc major
telecommunications companies as well as
viacom cbs
in a statement the company's ceo said it
is cooperating with the fbi
the intelligence community and law
enforcement the washington post reported
the russia-affiliated hacking group
known as cozy bear
breached email systems in some cases the
group has
direct ties to russian intelligence and
was allegedly behind hacking attacks
against the democratic national
committee in 2015
and in july the u.s britain and canada
accused cozy bear of attempting to steal
coronavirus
vaccine research the kremlin this
morning denied any involvement in the
hack we don't know
how large the cyber attack was or what
exactly hackers acquired in their
breaches
late sunday the department of homeland
security's cyber security arm
ordered all federal agencies to look for
any signs of potential
products anthony very scary catherine
thank you